hi there Steve Kaufman here again again
you're going to hear my wife
play the gun on the background I'm going
to talk about frequently asked questions
in language learning first of all a
question that was asked about the map
that you'll see back here and that's a
map an old map of Eastern Canada you can
see Quebec and Ontario you can see the
Great Lakes Hudson's Bay Greenland so
someone asked about that yeah someone
asked me because I did a frequently
asked questions tip about listening
what about reading how do you read well
let me say that I think that reading is
one of the best ways to learn a language
to increase our understanding of a
language to increase our vocabulary in
fact I think reading is a wonderful tool
is at the core of Education and these in
the academic sense you know education
can mean many things obviously we have
to learn about you know we have to learn
life skills we have to learn many
professional skills but for much of the
knowledge that we need to acquire
including language skills reading is
just since a tremendous path to learning
relatively inexpensive libraries
everywhere and this is true in the terms
of literacy in your own language it's
true in terms of learning a second
language it's inexpensive you don't need
a teacher so what are my own preferences
in terms of reading remember again that
it's not based on any science here it's
based on what I like to do basically if
I am a beginner in a language I write I
like to read very simple dialogues
where I can see a vocabulary list for
each little lesson that I'm looking at
and I'll read listen and I'll combine
the two and I'll listen much more
frequently than I read then as I
progress I would say within three months
I want to be reading authentic content I
am NOT one that likes reading graded
readers I know a lot of people use
graded readers and enjoy them I don't
the only case where I would read sort of
dumbed down simplified text is if it's
nonfiction so that it's a history of you
know Egypt if I'm learning Arabic or
geography of North Africa or Lebanon or
something in other words if it's a
nonfiction book dumbed down on something
of interest related to the language that
I'm learning then I will read the
simplified text but otherwise I prefer
to get into the offending language as
soon as possible that's why I in the old
days would read texts where there were
glossary is for each chapter and that is
essentially why I developed link because
the glossary is were so disappointing
they either didn't have the word that I
needed to look up or they had words that
I already knew plus it was a distraction
to flip back to the glossary so I prefer
at least for the first you know quite
long while in the language
I'll just read on the Internet I'll read
on my computer in later I can look up
words and save them for review now of
course I can go through quick link and
then read on my iPad so I don't have to
sit in front of the computer but I read
in a in an environment where I am helped
with my reading and the goal is then to
get to where I can read without help a
book because it's much more pleasant to
read a book or even in Kindle or
something but not to have to be sitting
in front of a computer so that's the
goal but it takes a while to get there I
am very much Pro listening because I can
listen anywhere anytime while I'm doing
other tasks I can't do that when read
but if I have dedicated learning time I
prefer to read rather than to listen if
I'm going to say I'm gonna do something
in the language I was at done read I
think reading is tremendously powerful
some person someone asks do I read more
often than once I do at the beginning
but very quickly I only want to read
once I'm I listen more often than I read
I'll typically read once although I will
often review stuff that I did six months
earlier and this is another thing when I
read I underlined I underlined words I
divided phrases I want to train my brain
to focus on what's happening in the
language so in that sense if I read
something that I did six months earlier
and I see my under linings and I see
that now I I'm used to those phrases
it's very encouraging so I went a bit
longer than I'm trying to keep these two
three max four minutes but that's my
take on reading I hope that's useful
thank you for